sixty million Americans of all races
voted for Donald Trump in 2016 according
to MSNBC every single one of them is an
evil person every single one of them is
a totally racy racy racist you don't get
to say I'm for racial equality and all
these good things I disagree with them
there but I like his economic views I'm
gonna vote for no you own it you own the
blood that happens it used to be well
we're against illegal immigration but
were for illegal immigration that was
the party's historical stance now it
looks increasingly like under Donald
Trump the Republican Party's hostile
towards all immigrants if you are
supporting a president that is caging
brown babies and you are okay with that
then I'm sorry that is supporting racist
policies and that is not distinct from
supporting a racist president and what
is the solution for this rampant racism
MSNBC contributor le mystile says he
knows Trump voters have to be
annihilated
these Trump supporters are just as
complicit in his cruelty as the man
himself
you know don't communicate it to them
you beat them you beat them they are not
a majority of this country the majority
of white people in this country are not
a majority of the country and all the
people who are not fooled by this need
to come together go to the polls go to
the protests do whatever you have to do
you do not negotiate with these people
you destroy them and you destroy them
Robbie swab is an associate editor
Driessen and the author of panic attack
young radicals in the age of Trump and
he joins us Robby is this a smart move
for Democrats and liberals to go down
this path I guess we'll find out but I
can't imagine that this is a sound and
winning political strategy to tell the
exact kind of person you need to bring
back into the Democratic fold rural
voters moderate voters people who didn't
like Hillary Clinton and maybe
wouldn't have supported Republicans
normally but Trump spoke to them people
in Rust Belt states in the Midwest I
mean Pennsylvania and Michigan could
decide this election
there's no way telling those people
there irredeemably racist and there's
nothing they can do to solve that by
just by virtue of being white
you're already no good and you should be
annihilated which which by the way is a
popular idea sort of in academia coming
out of the very progressive woke wing of
sociology critical studies etc that
check your priveledge microaggressions
all that which which is making its way
into the broader culture I mean they had
a few minutes in the last debate right
where where Gillibrand and others had to
check all their privileges and explain
how they would lecture and berate white
women who voted for Trump and so on all
of this is so self-defeating and and it
it worry it worries me that we'll never
have it have a intelligent debate over
issues over policy when it's just this
name-calling and shaming that turns
everyone off it turns them off we know
that polls show that so it's a terrible
idea if you think of some of these
broken-down rural communities the the
mills have gone the factories have gone
there's no work they're hollowed out by
heroin and opioid addiction in these
states where a hundred thousand folks
could turn things in 2020 do you think
these do you think the the people on
MSNBC seriously think these broken-down
white communities live lives of white
privilege right exactly you know I was
at a protest once at the University of
Michigan covering it and a liberal
protester once said well we're not
trying to convince anyone cuz we're not
gonna win them anyway we're not gonna
get any way there's no way we could
attract new people to our philosophy so
we have to scare them or we have to
intimidate them we don't want them to
feel safe leaving their homes probably
or going out to restaurants that's the
the sentiment and the expression there's
no more debate being had where we've
written off this this part of America
and we're not speaking to their issues
yeah and like what likewise that you you
can't convince an MN
MSNBC guy that the the president and his
voters aren't racist thank you thank you
for that Robbie